Gina got mad Jana said she's not coming
Jada's go boycott fascist j-dub
boycotting the Oscars is like me
boycotting Rihanna's panties I wasn't
invited the only act did you ever see at
the Oscars and when people act like
they're not mad they lost but I remember
one year when our Halle Berry won the
Oscar Nicole Kidman was smiling so wide
she shouldn't want to any actor Oscars
but huh great performance how you doing
just God you sound like an old-ass man
at my age the warranty begins to run out
I don't know and people say well dear do
you feel alright otherwise no I feel
like hell well more or less
I don't know that it would hold up in
court
[Applause]
wife's no manager I really like to fight
for jobs I hate the feeling of suddenly
being like oh well you know Kristen can
have it because she'll just because she
can I I am you know what I mean I don't
know what the hell you're talking about
give me the job
okay everybody's better than me
those other parts for a Mexican yeah did
he offer you an appearance in a movie
yeah it's weird I had a deal with Lucien
hold the the manager of the comic strip
where if I stack chairs after the show
he'd let me go on late so I just went to
go stack chairs and as I get to the club
any Murphy comes out of the bathroom
right and I didn't just see Eddie Murphy
it was Eddie Murphy in 19 whatever 87 I
mean Eddie Murphy is cool now but in 87
it was really Eddie Murphy man where
we're like leather suits in like Elvis
now yeah like a ring on leather gloves
or diamond rings on it like the guys
like I met the guy from raw like that
Eddie Murphy I didn't meet dr. Doolittle
so the manager introduces me to Eddie
and Eddie goes hey what time you going
on I was like well I'm not really on
tonight and then Eddie looks over at
Lucien it goes put them on Nick's yeah
so now I got an audience with the King
I'm like I'm next and I go up and I do
my my schtick or whatever it was that
night and the crowd is laughing and then
I heard it
[Applause]
I did it we haven't haven't had you on
the show I've been a guest here since
you hosted the Academy Awards
congratulations on that it's like a
thrill of a lifetime
you enjoyed yourself you know what's
weird I was scared when I saw solution
because I got to sit there and I got to
watch I probably watched a hundred you
know 70 whatever ask so I watched all
the Oscars and I watched when you hosted
yeah and like you can't be like that you
can't do that no matter what you do
don't do it let them and did they stop
after I did that award should they stop
making movies for a year or a year
nobody made any movies see you on the
toilet introducing what's an enormous
responsibility and frankly I'm lucky to
still be in show business
yes but I mean you held up under the
pressure quite well although some people
I guess that had their nose out of joint
but I know you were just kidding around
I'm just capable can't take jokes take
it big and these actor types yeah that's
right
just trying to have some fun guys right
Jennifer Lopez here tonight Jennifer
Lopez that's right that's right
she came with two limos one for how fast
[Applause]
oh yeah you don't think yes or no
I see Jennifer on TV thinking a mom or
dad in a hackney-coach thank you ass
girl thank you that's my foot ass go
solo
to the answers the star the show
Jennifer just the Commodores the ass is
Lionel Richie I had I had to go down a
list and apologize to people who had
their had their nose out of joint for
some something I had screwed up on the
Academy Awards did you go through any of
that I guess your people I was just
gonna say kiss my ass now you gotta
watch where you sit everybody can't sit
50 Dench I'll roll you can't sit jay-z
their knives everybody gotta watch out
for you got the Olsen twins over there
so then you got to put our Kelly way up
there
so even if you get shot by a stray
bullet you won't have to go to no doctor
to get it taken out whoever shot you
take they put it back I believe you got
my property
[Applause]